okay first of all can we just like have
a moment
hi we're gonna have a moment for being
in real life
in person no zoom no zooms we're
officially
here in real life we're in the belly of
the beast right we're happy right now
we're in chatsworth california and i
never pictured my business as being here
but this is where a lot of warehouses
are for the cosmetic industry so a lot
of your
favorites that you see in sephora and
ulta are next door and
everyone is shipping from chatsworth
mainly it's nuts and you have like
multiple warehouses right yes an office
space
we really we started across the street
in a little building um and now we have
five huge buildings so one of five
yes that is so wild who knew like
chatsworth was where you needed to be to
build your own ideas right
you're in the uh the archives right now
this is you're in my office
literally every product you've ever made
right right behind us yes ever made does
it make you emotional kind of walking
into this it really does because i
remember it just feels like it feels
like yesterday
i launched three lipstick shades right
so we're about to be
seven years in in november i have over
600 skus and i'm just like
we're here like i feel like maybe we
actually get a tour of this place to
really
see you in action can i yeah i think we
should
i would love that i would love to do a
little tour let's do it i love it
okay so um i don't think there's enough
pink in the office not
right i love pink carpet so this is my
main office this is where a lot of the
ideas are created in my
uh wild brain and this is where you'll
see me doing a lot of zoom still
really well you have the perfect
backdrop isn't it
so is this your miranda priestly moment
like this is where it happens absolutely
that's all that's all that's all this is
a nice little presidential barbie desk
so what was the inspiration for the
decor
oh i this was like very early jeffree
star cosmetics
when we everything was pink i had to let
the world know
were going to be the brightest brand on
the block right so i want it very me
it is very you i can feel it i can feel
the energy so from here yeah what
tickets through the
so we could go this way but or we could
go behind this hidden door oh
nothing wild no willy wonka you don't
know which way you're going
okay okay oh so you may be surprised but
a lot of people
are actually working yeah yes that
actually working and uh working from
home oh okay so usually you would see us
um a sea of people but and i heard that
it really started
this whole empire started with four
people and now it's this isn't that wow
that is really really awesome so how
many people in staff do you have
lost count over 150 yeah which is
business people wild
awesome
um so where are you taking us next we're
gonna go in the warehouse okay
in the hub and hub yeah the true belly
of the beast of the jeffree
[Music]
so it's not even shipping this is just
where the inventory shows up first so
these are a lot of new collections and
we have to blur out a few boxes
and in this building we have a cold
storage okay which we use a lot of times
for like stick lipsticks and products
that can't be
in a normal you know hotter temperature
so so yeah this is just racks and racks
of makeup this one's wild
it is really crazy it's so cool i'm like
i'm like i see
i see the orgy palette yeah yeah it's
okay
yes oh so cool all right so should we go
to the cold room
of course oh that's cool all right baby
let me move my forklift i got
proof that jeffree star really does do
it all especially when it comes to his
own business this is my this is my pink
palette jack
and she is amazing we have a lot of
these and usually you just put those in
there and then
lift them up crank it up baby hey you
better tuck it through the mask jumped
out
all right let's go behind the curtain
okay so here we go here we go
now this is our cold storage which is uh
temperature controlled to 70 degrees at
all times
for all the cosmetics yes so things that
can't
get really hot like stick lipsticks lip
liners
um those have to stay in here okay
they'll melt i love it
um so what is a typical day like for you
in the office like how often are you
roaming the square house oh
so i'm here whenever i can be right in
between youtube videos
um shoots for the brand which we can go
to star studios beautiful yes so i'm
here as much as i can be but a lot of
the times like with covet we all have
meetings at my house
which i'm sure is convenient but did you
miss your babies absolutely you know
i i got old just sitting at home i
really did i i needed to be
i feel more productive in an environment
with my office and everything around
me all right where do you want to take
us next oh okay let's go this is the
boss's car
the boss is here grudger loins okay okay
well
you see you peep that plate look at it
you're always on brand oh you got the
wyoming plate
yeah you can film the plate and
obviously not blur it
isn't she cute she's gorgeous all of it
so this is official then it's official
it's official
how cute is this oh your land is inside
baby okay
tell me this is not a perfect pink
confection is this not insane
you look insane in front of it this is
the most custom rolls-royce cullinan on
the planet
and i can't believe it's mine i can't
believe it that's insane right i've
never been in a car this rich before
okay hi okay listen i used to have a
1991 nissan sentra yeah so the fact that
anyone even made me a car come on it's
kind of hard to fathom sometimes
goals right this is the best because
when you're on the freeway and you just
are not in the mood for anyone you got a
curtain to close oh i thought you're
going to say i have an eject button
[Laughter]
this car has a refrigerator in it
stocked with red bull of course
absolutely yes okay like you do this is
the car you go out when you don't want
to be noticed
it's very low key you ain't touching my
emblem
hey what's that scene in mrs doubtfire
like he rips the little thing off the
car
this is how far i did it to pierce
that's iconic isn't it all right we're
gonna have a little walk
okay and by the way in case anyone needs
to know it is over 100 degrees today it
is really hot this is why you went to
wyoming
all right welcome to star studio okay
we're here we made it okay all right so
what
goes down here so this is where we shoot
all of our campaigns okay
um everything you see online with the
crazy the jawbreaker machine the velvet
trap it's a pulse
shot here oh cool yeah it's awesome so
come in come in
here's where we keep a lot of our sets
that we've already shot okay
so you guys may be familiar with the
blood sugar tooth the blood money
big old star right and then we need you
on the on the venus flight trap
don't threaten me with a good time
jeffrey okay
oh wow isn't this nuts and this is the
okay this is for our velvet trap
that's right yeah okay this is iconic
what do you do with this now
i we we keep a lot of the stuff for
archives because we want to make a
jeffree star museum one day
of course so you'll see behind him the
jawbreaker machine and all that stuff
isn't it nuts so here's my question yeah
we created this from nothing just i was
like we need a
i need a giant life-size venus flytrap
and my set designer said
yes ma'am iconic i mean you could also
recycle this for like a fun halloween
costume shoe
or something just put it in the entrance
of your house that part do that
i can see this in wyoming right on the
ranch okay
um isn't it cool you mentioned a
possible jeffree star museum
is there a timeline for that and also
will it be in california
wyoming new york i think it has to be in
california don't you think i do yeah
just because there's so it's a hub it's
entertainment i think when i'm ready to
slow things down in a few years i would
love to
start one up but for now we're just
hoarding them all
you know what this is the letters from
the orgy palette
there's the cheese uh cheese block from
oh you're good it might my heels might
pop through it's a quarantine
wait the quarantine way okay okay
we both flip come on after you
a board mission well obviously i
couldn't you know come visit you jeffrey
without turning into you so thank you so
much
what do we think about this color on you
though why do i live because it just
complements you too i feel like i should
be your sidekick i mean i don't know if
you need another collab
partner okay look at this okay so
what room is this this is the wardrobe
room usually there's a bunch of models
in me in here and it's
just packed to the ceiling do you do
fittings here too yes we do
look how iconic this is isn't this all
right this is my
famous pink chair i love it you know
what i'm gonna say it officially
you invented the color pink jeffy thank
you okay you did
this is such a fun place i'm gonna take
this off real quick because i want to
know give her a throw
oh bam like that yeah
that was crazy um think first of all
thank you so much for having us of
course
it really is inspiring to see your
empire
and have the hub here uh what advice do
you have for people
who have big dreams like yours who maybe
come from a place where they're like
that's
not possible yes i have the same
thoughts but
i think through my entire career i
always was hearing no
right even was that when i was trying to
be a musician there was a lot of no's a
lot of nose and even in the beauty space
it was oh
that brand maybe a little too crazy your
ideas may be a little too nuts right and
i always just stuck to what i knew
i wanted to do and i never listened to
the noise so don't listen to anyone
follow your dreams always believe in
yourself and do you because we only have
one life right
you have to live every day authentically
was there one lesson that you learned
along the way
that you're like okay that's never gonna
happen again oh
um i think with like customer service
stuff yeah and like being a boss
remember like i came from being a
musician
so i had to teach myself how to be a ceo
absolutely right so there's a lot of
bumps a lot of curves um and i really
i think i've mastered it you have the
rainbow collection
yes what do you want fans to know about
it now listen i'm so
grateful and thankful that um everyone
has sold out on the sweat suit already i
can't believe it i'm about to go in the
warehouse and look for it yeah
okay but we still have a few of the
rainbow star mirrors left they're going
so quick
and yeah it's it's available now in
jeffree star cosmetics.com
for the od foundation charity and the
next collection is already in the brain
or even better
in this in the office already it's in
the office i could show you off camera
and is coming out end of july and it is
next level you don't quit never never
stops
i love it never stop never stop what's
next for the jeffree star empire can we
ever see you like
on dancing with the stars or something
i'm kind of down for that but i kind of
more want to be
like on a netflix series where i'm an
actor and i'm not jeffree star
i'm like in prison or like i mean like
like like
like a show having like a prison break
you're like oh you want something very
different yeah
okay i was going to see maybe he's into
it with like the sex and the city
revival oh
like could you fly over to new york and
just like cute i could be carrie's best
friend for a second
and then transition to the yard but you
would be down to act
like i'll say like six feet under or
like dexter like just shows that are
just so
dark different and dark and yeah i would
love that i love that okay well thanks
again you are
of course in a word iconic thank you so
much i appreciate your time